merci la parole à Monsieur Pierre
Charron pour le groupe UMP
monsieur le Président
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur
monsieur le ministre dimanche 24 mars
dernier les opposants à la loi dite de
mariage pour tous se sont à nouveau
réunis pour une manifestation familiale
et pacifique une fois de plus vos
services sont annoncés des chiffres de
participation aberrant confirmé encore
hier soir à 300 000 qui démontrent une
volonté délibérée de mentir aux Français
afin de minimiser la réalité de ce
mouvement de contestation énorme
mouvement de conseils stations vous avez
ainsi égaré le 13 janvier 700 000
manifestants et plus d'un million cette
fois-ci je conçois que le gouvernement
soit agacé par la détermination et la
mobilisation massive des opposants à ce
texte mais c'est agacement ne serait ni
justifié la manipulation grossière des
chiffres ni les instructions données par
vous-même de la salle de commandement de
la PP assistée du préfet de police
comment expliquer vous l'utilisation de
ce que vous appelez les aéros sur les
femmes les pères de famille et les
enfants
jusqu'à présent les aérosols sert plus
pour les asthmatiques que pour les
manifestants pourquoi pas des
vaporisateurs non plus alors qu'il
s'agit de l'acrymogène disons les mots
n'ayez pas peur des mots vous savez
parler de groupe extrémistes hier encore
l'Assemblée nationale fortement secoué
par mes collègues députés mais monsieur
le ministre je ne sais pas si quelques
agités ont pu se faufiler dans la foule
mais toutes les images et les vidéos
sont accablantes pour vous et vos
services vos extrémistes sont des
fillettes de huit ans des personnes
âgées des bonnes soeurs des familles
nombreuses et des élus de la République
rendez publique les nombreuses plaintes
de journalistes contre vos services qui
ont été déposés à la PP d'ailleurs à
l'heure où je vous parle un enfant de 14
ans est toujours hospitalisé ne sachant
pas s'il récupérait l'usage d'un œil
monsieur le ministre quand le pouvoir
s'en prose enfants c'est la République
qui saigne comment pouvez-vous expliquer
aux Français qu'une semaine plus tôt les
CRS étaient restés impassibles devant
les syndicats de PSA qui faisaient
brûler des pneus sur cette même avenue
de la Grande Armée
comment pouvez-vous affirmer que les
organisateurs ont été débordés par la
manifestation pardon ce sont vos
services de renseignement qu'il avait
encore prévoyé 100000 personnes au doigt
mouillé effectivement si vous attendiez
15 fois moins de manifestants il n'est
pas anormal que vos services aient été
débordés et que l'on déplore ces
incidents c'est une responsabilité du
préfet de police de Paris monsieur
Boucau d'avoir figé une manifestants
sans prévoir d'ici au cortège vous savez
ce que c'est ça revient à peu près à
remplir une boîte de nuit sans senti de
secours cela dit quand Hollande un
directeur de l'ENA patron du maintien de
l'ordre et que l'on court entre les
fauteuils du Grand Rex et la salle de
commandement de la PP il ne faut pas
s'étonner que ça déborde c'est pourquoi
Monsieur le Ministre devant l'absence de
vos réponses nous avons décidé avec un
certain nombre de collègues sénateurs de
demander l'ouverture d'une commission
d'enquête afin qu'elle éclaircisse les
conditions dans laquelle la préfecture
n'a pas anticipé n'a pas encadré et à
menti aux Français
cela participation merci la parole est à
Monsieur Manuel Valls ministre de
l'Intérieur
c'est le président monsieur le sénateur
et que cherchez-vous
monsieur Charron à remettre en cause la
parole de l'État
celle du préfet de police a contesté par
ailleurs la légitimité du Parlement
celle des représentants de la nation
vous allez être saisi d'un texte celui
du mariage pour tous dans quelques jours
qui ont majoritairement adopté à
l'Assemblée nationale le projet de loi à
l'Assemblée nationale
vous avez gouverné vous avez assumé des
responsabilités vos amis pas vous et
après ce que j'ai entendu heureusement
monsieur Charron vous avez été confronté
à des mouvements sociaux à la nécessité
du maintien de l'ordre à la colère aussi
des Français et là vous venez donner des
leçons ici
monsieur Charron vous qui avez souvent
fréquenté vous qui avez souvent
fréquenté la préfecture de police vous
savez parfaitement que la méthode de
comptage est la même pour tous les
rassemblements et tous les
manifestations la même qui est utilisée
depuis des années et le chiffre de
300000 qui peut penser et le chiffre de
300000 est déjà très important mais qui
peut penser que dans Paris il y avait
dimanche dernier plus d'un million de
manifestants enfin ça n'a aucun sens et
pourquoi pas de millions et pourquoi 3
millions vous essayez le tromper les
Français sur ce sujet là et ce chiffre
de 300 000 vient d'être démontré et
derrière vos accusations il y a des
professionnels des fonctionnaires
consciencieux il y avait 2000 policiers
et gendarmes dimanche dernier 2000 et
c'était adapté aux chiffres que nous
avions parce que nous savions qu'il y
avait à peu près le même nombre non
ne croyez pas vous officines vous avez
trop fréquenté monsieur Charron vous
avez trop aux fréquenté les officines de
la République et vous savez bien de quoi
il s'agit et derrière
et la preuve et d'ailleurs je les tiens
à vos dispositions les photographies de
la manifestation ont été publiés hier et
vous le savez sur le site de la
préfecture de police parce que nous
n'avons rien à cacher les manifestants
ont annoncé un chiffre mais quel mode de
comptage ont-ils utiliser ou pensez
pouvoir confirmer sa fiabilité c'était
peut-être l'une de vos rares
manifestations à moins que vous y
participer à d'autres manifestations il
y a quelques années
vous voyez cette polémique n'a pas lieu
d'être les débordements qui ont eu lieu
alors même que les consignes de la
préfecture étaient claires sont
inacceptables et quand on se réclame
souvent sur d'autres sujets du parti de
l'ordre il est bien étonnant de voir ici
un parlementaire salué ceux qui s'en
prennent aux forces de l'ordre
il y a eu
il y a eu de nombreux appels répétés sur
Internet et sur les réseaux sociaux pour
braver une décision préfectorale pour
braver une décision préfectorale
confirmée et je vous le rappelle par le
tribunal administratif de Paris enfin
les organisateurs ne pouvaient ignorer
et vous ne pouvez pas l'ignorer et là
aussi les photos les images les médias
l'ont montré le rôle des extrémistes du
Bloc Identitaire je le rappelle des
Jeunesses nationalistes du Renouveau
français du guide d'Europe jeunesse qui
était sur place et qui brandissait leurs
bras devant les forces de l'ordre et ça
aussi monsieur Charron vous l'excuser et
vous trouvez normal que vous à
parlementaire acceptiez qu'il y a des
hommes qui soient mis en cause les
forces de l'ordre sont intervenus et moi
je suis cohérent il ne peut pas y avoir
dans une démocratie le moindre
débordements et les forces de l'ordre le
préfet de police et vous n'avez pas le
droit ici au Sénat à l'assemblée de
mettre en cause un homme d'État qui est
le préfet Bernard Boucau c'est
inacceptable c'est d'une lâcheté
inacceptable